this chart right over here is at bls.gov
BLS stands for the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and in
a pretty interesting Trend here it shows
that the higher the degree level that
someone gets it is associated with
higher median weekly earnings right
because they're saying median usual
weekly earnings and you could also see
it's associated with lower and lower
unemployment the higher of a degree you
get
so one takeaway from this might be well
if you want to make more money and if
you want to have lower unemployment and
I think those are things that most
people Aspire for it might make sense to
have higher and higher level of degrees
or get more and more education
now I will put a few uh disclaimers on
that because it's not necessarily the
fact that the education is causing the
higher income it might be the fact that
people who are really organized who are
really hard working who are doing well
academically which are all ingredients
for maybe success that those people also
just decide to get more education and
then they become more successful it's
probably in my mind a combination of
both the actual education does make you
actually more trained and more capable
and more ready for the workforce and it
also opens doors for you that wouldn't
have been opened otherwise but there is
an aspect of the same person who might
have gotten a doctoral degree if you
were able to run an experiment and they
weren't able to get a doctoral degree
maybe they might be just as successful
we'll never know because you it's very
hard to run that exact same experiment
but generally speaking more education
does seem to help it does look like it's
an investment in your earnings and in
your employability so to speak another
thing to think about you might just look
at this and say oh if I want to be as
little unemployed as possible or make as
much possible money as possible I should
either go get a PhD or I should get a
professional degree like become a lawyer
or become a doctor
and that might be true in certain cases
but not all degrees are going to be
equal in terms of employability and
equal in terms of earnings for example
there's some bachelor's degrees that can
make very good money oftentimes a lot
more money than a doctoral degree or
professional degree for example if you
were to major in some types of
engineering or I guess computer science
which is also a high demand I guess
that's that's also part of engineering
there could even be Associate's degrees
that pay very very well a lot of the
trades would go become an electrician
become a plumber can pay better in many
cases than some folks who get a PhD so
you just need to think about not just
the level of education but which
particular field you're going into and
maybe more importantly is that going to
be a field where you think you can
Thrive and really dig into that career
and make something out of it but I think
the combination of saying hey in general
more education is probably a good thing
as long as you don't take it for granted
that just the degree by itself is what's
going to make you successful and you're
very thoughtful about picking a path not
just how far you want to go but the
actual Lane you want to go in that both
you believe based on information talking
to folks gives you good Financial
prospects and it's one that you're going
to thrive in because you could go and
become a doctor but if that's not
something that you wake up every morning
like oh I love being a doctor and you at
some point you're like I don't want to
become a doctor anymore then the degrees
probably not going to help you as much
it might help you get some other type of
Health Care job or something so just
think about these things but this is a
general chart that hey maybe maybe
education is a good investment